[موسيقى]
الصين الان بلا ادنى
شكوى كبرى او وكل هذا يعود الى اواخر
السبعينات القرن الماضي عندما قامت بفتح
الاقتصاد الصيني مما قادر
الكبيره جدا عبر العقود الماضيه مما سمحها
لصيني يمارس سيتي ثقلها عسكريا ودبلوماسيا
ايضا
موقفه حينها هو لنحافظ على الهدوء ونعز
قواتنا والان حصل وصلوا الى هذه القوه الى
الحد الذي تستطيع ان تقوم فيه اسهامات
ايجابيه مثل مجال تحدثنا عنه وتخفيض
التوترات في الخليج العربي منجم مصلحه
الجميع هنالك مناطق اخرى خاصه في شرق
الهادئ حيث الولايات المتحده والصين
بالتحديد لديهما خلافات وهنالك احتمال
لخروج التواترات عن الطاقه السيطره وهذا
يقلقنا جميعا ولكن حقيقه وصول الصين على
انها من القوى الكبرى في العالم وصولها
لهذه المرحله اتمنى ان تتساهم بايجابيه
اكثر من السلبيه
[موسيقى]
اعتقد بان الصينيين بكل حضاره سيختارون
الحالات او الاوضاع التي يدخلون فيها ولن
يبذلوا جهود الدبلوماسيه لا يرون فيها
املا كبيرا بالنجاح ولا اعتقد انهم يرون
املا كبيرا من النجاح اذا ما ارادوا
التدخل بشكل مباشر في النزاع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني فسوف يستنتجون كما استنتج
الكثيرون بين طرف الخارجي الاساسي
نظرا للعلاقات القويه جدا بين امريكا
واسرائيل لذلك اشكوا بان الصينيين
سيحاولون التداخل في هذا النزاع
[موسيقى]